schaut mal was bei mir mit der Post
ankam ein pr-paket von Lush und zwar mit
den neuen Produkten zu dem Super Mario
Brothers Film und ich habe dann erstmal
diesen Fragezeichen Cube ins Wasser
geworfen ich liebe die Badebomben von
Lush die sind einfach so schön ich meine
guckt mal an das sieht einfach aus wie
ein Kunstwerk wie das glitzert und diese
Badewanne da will man sich einfach
reinsetzen ja und dann war da drin
einfach ein Pilz eine kleine
Überraschung und das kann man als ähm
Duschgel benutzen so ein festes und dann
habe ich auch noch das Mario Duschgel
ausprobiert das außer wie Blut ich meine
es hat nicht abgefärbt aber okay das
Luigi Duschgel braucht auch so ein
bisschen nach Apfel und so richtig
lecker und ja schäumt perfekt und macht
mich sauber und das Princess Peach jelly
Duschgel ist vom Geruch mein Favorit
aber ich finde es einfach viel zu lustig
wie sich das in der Hand anfühlt da muss
man sich dran gewöhnen danke fürs
zuhören